one bright spot yesterday was an intense
rally on Wall Street during the
president's declaration of a national
emergency stocks finished up almost two
thousand points the biggest one-day
percentage gain since the 2008 financial
crisis and it came just a day after the
biggest one-day loss since the 1987
Black Monday crash joining us to discuss
the extreme volatility in what may lie
ahead is Andy serwer editor-in-chief of
Yahoo Finance Andy good morning good
morning you know I mentioned stocks
finish up but there's so much volatility
it seemed to be just what the stock
market needed was that speech by the
president but we're not out of the woods
are we no no way I mean and listen I'm
trying to get a little relief here on
Saturday because that was a crazy week
for people who follow the markets what a
roller coaster and I think that we have
to expect more volatility in the days
and weeks to come because of all this
uncertainty it's such an old saw but
it's true Wall Street hates uncertainty
and this is uncertainty writ large and
the Treasury secretary minuchin said
we're in the second inning right now of
stimulus efforts talk about what effect
you think those stimulus efforts can
have and how long it takes yeah I mean
there are a lot of options that the
government has right now and I think
they're going through them and they're
trying to see how effective some of the
things that they've already done are
which are say interest rate cuts and
then also the measures of the president
announced yesterday afternoon but going
forward they can do things like cut
payroll taxes send checks directly to
families increase government spending
and backstop the private sector and
especially workers who get laid off
that's a real concern for us and for the
economy because especially now that we
have so many people working in the gig
economy they're not protected at all we
really need to look at that very closely
yeah to that point as people are in
crisis mode they're wondering what do we
do do we look to our 401k take out loans
I mean which should folks be doing as
these businesses or clothes are
shuttering or shutting down operations
and
what should folks do yeah well the thing
about the 401k of course is so scary and
you know it's probably a good idea not
to do too much at all as far as that is
concerned because you're gonna be
selling when the markets going down
which is just the wrong time you really
need to understand also what your
options are and how protected you are in
terms of a layoff or in terms of sick
leave or medical leave you need to
really go through that with your HR
department if you're lucky enough to
work at a big company at a smaller
company talk to your boss talk to your
co-workers try to understand how exposed
you are and then follow what's going on
in terms of government action because
you may actually need relief from the
government be at the federal or the
state or the local level and worth
keeping it all in perspective - Andy
Emmy so what the last eleven years right
the market was at just over six thousand
the dow in 2009 went almost thirty
thousand just a few weeks ago now it's
back down to twenty three you tell
people to look at your 401k accounts
right now yeah you just you just can't
look at them I mean we always say just
don't look and at some point you know
things will bounce back I don't know if
it's this year next year three years
five years but you know it's the
American economy which is a pretty good
bet over the long haul Andy serwer thank
you for the insight